- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape;
bipedal, naked large-brained. Lone the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Brenna] Thank you so much for having
me. So, unlike most of your other
speakers, I actually work with
contemporary humans and not fossils, but I
will try to maintain your attention
anyway. I am mostly interested in human
evolution. And as you've noticed from
these diagrams that people have put up
regarding the phylogeny of Neanderthals
and Denisovans and modern humans, modern
humans often get represented as sort of
just a single branch, or maybe a few
genomes that come off this other branch.
And so what I want to do is really take a
little bit of time and conceptualize what
it means to refer to the Homo sapiens as a
single species. Did we have a single
origin. There's actually a lot of
complexity in this question which isn't
necessarily addressed by one of these
simple tri-part type phylogenies. So,
let's just break down kind of the known
working model we have for human evolution
which is mostly based on contemporary DNA.
So, if we start out in Africa roughly
about 100,000 years ago. I'm an advocate
of a Southern African origin. I'm not
going to try to convince you of that
today, but we actually don't know where in
Africa. There was a single origin of the
Homo sapiens species if indeed it was a
single origin model, all right? And then
from Southern Africa, putatively, there is
a migration and dispersal into the rest of
the African continent. And certainly by
60, maybe even slightly earlier, 70,000
years, there were these individuals living
in Northeastern Africa at which time there
was what we call a "founder event." So,
these populations moved out of Africa into
the near East. Now, this event is actually
a major event in human evolution, or at
least in the genomes of all non-Africans
living today. And that is because there
was a strong reduction in genetic
diversity during this founder event. And
that's indicated here by the fat arrow,
okay? So every time you see a fat arrow on
this map, that indicates a reduction in
genetic diversity. Once humans left
Africa, these individuals spread rapidly
across the Eurasian continent. There are
some hypotheses of what they call the
South Indian or South Asian migration
route which is along the coast of the
Indian subcontinent, and eventually into
Southeast Asia and Oceania, certainly by
45,000 years ago. As well as additional
migrations into Northern Asia and
eventually into the Americas where it was
accompanied by yet another strong founder
event or population bottleneck which
reduced the genetic diversity of those
populations. And we'll hear a little bit
more about that today from Maria. So
that's our basic model of human evolution
over the last 100,000 years. But you'll
notice that there's not a lot of detail in
Africa, actually. There's just a few
arrows and some general little dates.
Geneticists love to put arrows on maps and
I am no exception. So, I'd like to instead
think about posing this question, "Where
in Africa did humans originate?" And there
are different types of genetic evidence or
other types of evidence one might use to
answer this question. And there's a sort
of presentation here. This is by Batini
and Jobling where they suggest different
types of evidence one could look at. So
you could look at, for example,
non-genetic evidence, skulls that have
been dug up from the ground by
paleo-anthropologists. You could look at
evidence of what we call "symbolic
behaviors," such as the making of art, so
shell beads or these little crosshatch
ocher pieces that have been discovered.
You might even look at language. So
there's a really fascinating paper from a
few years ago that looked at phonemic
diversity, not genetic diversity, but
looking at the number of phonemes in
different languages and can we learn
anything about the origins of language by
the amount of diversity that's present in
phonemes? And he argued, indeed, Africa
has the highest phonemic diversity. And in
particular even Southern African has the
highest phonemic diversity. So I'm a
geneticist. I focus on a different type of
evidence and you can break down genetic
evidence also into these little patches.
So one might be the mitochondrial DNA.
Mitochondrial DNA, as we've heard from
other speakers, is something that's
inherited through the maternal lineage. So
the mother passes it on to her children
and then it's passed on from the daughter
to her children. Alternatively, you could
look at the Y-chromosome which has a
different pattern of inheritance from
father to son, and so on and so on, for
many generations. And then last are what
we call the autosomes, which are the
remainder of the chromosomes 1 through 22
that compose the rest of your genome. So
when this was done, and this slide is a
little bit dated, but from mitochondrial
DNA and Y-chromosome DNA, it was a little
bit hard to pin-point precisely where the
deepest divergence was within Africa, I'm
going to address that again later, but at
least from the autosomal information. Both
if you look at SNPs or a single-nucleotide
polymorphism, just your vanilla mutation.
They actually have the highest genetic
diversity, or heterozygosity, in Southern
African populations and even other types
of polymorphism like microsatellites also
look like they had the highest diversity
in Southern African populations. And so
we're getting a lot of conflicting pieces
of information maybe from non-genetic
evidence, from genetic evidence. So how
can we sort of conceptualize synthesizing
all this information? So I'm actually an
anthropologist by training, despite the
fact that I do genetics, and so I like to
sort of begin with the paleo-anthropology
and that's what we're going to do right
now. So there's a fantastic amount of
information that's been excavated from the
fossil record. And some of this
information comes in the form of bones,
right? Like we've seen earlier on the
talk. And on the right here, you have a
fossil cranium from Hurso, Ethiopia that
was dug up. And it looks
like...morphologically, it's very similar
to modern humans. So the front part of the
skull is actually tucked in underneath the
brow ridge. The skull is actually pretty
short from front to back. The brain size
is, of course, equivalent to what you
would see in contemporary human
populations today. And if we put flesh on
this individual, they would probably look
relatively similar to other human sapiens
around the world. However, so we know that
there was morphologically individuals that
were probably similar to Homo sapiens
walking around Africa at least 150,000
years ago. But in fact there's a lot of
additional information that can be gleamed
from stone tools. So, there is a phrase
that's called the "middle stone age." And
the middle stone age refers, at least
roughly to 250,000 years ago to 50,000
years ago. And on this other map, what you
see are sites in Africa where middle stone
age artifacts have been recovered. So we
know that hominin populations were living
in these areas of Africa during this time
period. And what you'll notice, right, is
that there is maybe not that many examples
of this beautifully reconstructed skull
from all over Africa, but there are many,
many geographic locations on this map that
actually date back to the middle stone
age. And so what does that mean? So that
means of course that there were lots of
hominins walking around the face of Africa
during this time period. And in fact
there's also good evidence from North
Africa as well, even though it's cut off
in this particular map. And so let's just
kind of make a little schematic and start
to think about this. So if I look back
into Africa 150,000 years ago, 200,000
years ago, I know that there are Homo
sapien-like populations, broadly speaking,
that exist in different parts of the
landscape. And so we can ask a relatively
simple question, "Were these populations
structured?" That means, are they
different from one another? So perhaps we
have populations in North Africa, East
Africa and Southern Africa. There is less
information from Central Africa for
various reasons. And these environments
may have been very different from one
another. So you might have had a cool,
Mediterranean climate up in North Africa
and then a very hot desert-like climate,
let's say, in Southern Africa. And the
question then is, are these populations
really separate from one another? Or are
individuals moving in between them? So
population geneticists like to refer to
this concept as population structure. So
let me just explain what that is briefly.
In this little schematic, we have a SNP,
or a single nucleotide polymorphism, up on
the top that either comes in red or
yellow. And we have two populations on
either side of this river and we can see
that they are very different from one
another. So individuals on one side of the
river carry only the red allele, and
individuals on the other side of the river
only carry the yellow allele. And this is
structured populations, or populations
where there are strong differences in
allele frequency. And this is in contrast,
down to the bottom, of populations which
are carrying both the purple and the
orange alleles because there is migration
between these two populations or gene
flow, if you refer to your little glossary
on the handout, and this is because I've
given them a nice little bridge so people
can walk across and migrate. So, we can
just sort of take that example and apply
it to the rest of Africa as well. So, were
these populations structured at 200,000
and 150,000 years ago? Or was there
actually what we call "panmixia" or lots
of migration among the different
sup-populations? And I think we have an
actual answer to this particular question,
but it's somewhat complicated to infer, in
fact. And one thing to point out is that
in either of these scenarios, if you're
thinking back to what the landscape would
have looked like 200,000 years ago, means
that if I went and sampled individuals
from across the African landscape, their
common ancestor, in terms of their
genetics, would have been very old. It
would actually pre-date 150,000 years ago
or 200,000 years ago. In order to
understand why that is, you have to again
take a little mini-class in population
genetics here and think about the
difference between populations and genes.
So this is what we call a "gene genealogy"
which is represented by these little
lineages right here. And these lineages
exist within these two different
populations, okay? So we can sort of trace
back the common ancestry of a given
genetic segment to where that individual
shares a common ancestor. And these common
ancestors exist in some ancestral
population which I'm going to then let
evolve through time. So now, we have this
common ancestral population and there's
been some sort of divergence and is
diverging to the blue and orange
populations. And you can see that these
gene genealogies, these genetic lineages,
are sort of splitting nicely into the blue
and orange population. And then finally,
at the present day, or down here. You
know, I might go and sample individuals
from the orange population and the blue
population and then ask when their common
ancestor was, okay? And that common
ancestor is indicated up here just like in
a normal phylogeny. The key thing to
remember actually when you're looking at
that is that the common ancestor pre-dates
the population divergence, okay? And this
is the case for most of the low side that
we would look at in the human genome. So,
the common ancestor must be older than the
population divergence. So then, we can
ask, "How old are the common genetic
lineages within human population?" So I'm
going to do this for a relatively simple
locus, the Y-chromosome, right? So the
Y-chromosome again is just passed on
between father and son. And one of the
nice things about the Y-chromosome is that
it's relatively small, so it's easy to go
in and sequence it from many individuals.
So, a few years ago, we captured about 10
megabases of the Y-chromosome from a
variety of individuals across human
populations and we actually had a strong
focus here on sampling African populations
because that's what I'm obsessed with, is
African populations. And what you'll see
is all the African individuals are sort of
on the bottom half of this segment and
you're just looking at a normal gene
genealogy or phylogeny that's been flipped
on it's side. So the common ancestor is
right here and then each one of these
lineages represents a single individual's
Y-chromosome that was sampled from a man.
Now the first thing obviously to notice is
that individuals from outside of Africa
have very little genetic diversity on
their Y-chromosomes compared to
individuals from Africa. And you can
easily see that by their relatively short
branch lengths up here. So these are all
the out of African individuals, okay? So
people from Cambodia, people from the
Americas, people from Europe and so on.
And instead if I look within Africa, I see
individuals that carry really, really long
branches, okay? So for example,
individuals from West Africa and North
Africa diverge around here. And
individuals that are from these African
hunter-gatherer populations, which are
particularly special, carry
extraordinarily long branches all the way
back to the common ancestor. So that graph
can be a little bit hard to read for some
people who are not geneticists so I've
tried to make a schematic. If we look at
the time to the common ancestor and we try
to date, in years, how long ago that might
have been, we can kind of put an upper
bound on the population divergence among
all human populations. And so when we do
this with the Y-chromosome, what you
actually see is that the upper bound on
population divergence would have been
around 150,000 years ago plus or minus a
couple of tens of thousands of years,
okay? So we're actually seeing relatively
shallow divergence among contemporary
human populations. And with a little bit
of additional modeling we can actually
say, "Well, which population diverged
first from all other human populations and
when was that?" And at least looking at
the Y-chromosome sequence it's most likely
to have been these Khoisan populations
from Southern Africa and we date it to
approximately around 90,000 years ago.
Now, you could say, "Well that's just the
Y-chromosome. It's just a single locus and
has this bizarre pattern of inheritance
from father to son." So independently,
there was additional papers published by
Renaut [SP] and also Veeramah
approximately about a year before we
published our Y-chromosome work, and they
actually independently came up with a very
similar estimate on this time of
population divergence between these
Southern African hunter-gatherer groups
and the other humans within Africa. And
that time of population divergence is
approximately 100,000 to 120,000 years
ago. So again, what you're seeing is that
the gene genealogies certainly go back in
time, but the actual time depth of this
population divergence is quite shallow,
okay? And if we try to map that on to
these sort of schematics of Africa, what
would that mean? It means that neither of
those two maps that I showed you before
could really represent the actual true
ancestors to the human population. So
something must have happened to reduce the
genetic diversity between 200,000 years
ago and 100,000 years ago. And so let's
just think for a moment what that might
have been or what that could have looked
like. So one hypothesis could be that
there was a strong population bottleneck
during this time period, 200,000 to
100,000 years ago. And maybe that
bottleneck was associated for example with
climate. So populations actually could
have moved from one region to another
because of climatic fluctuation. And in
this case, I've had all the individuals
that are living in Eastern Africa and
Northern Africa just sort of trickle down
and move into Southern Africa where things
were nicer during that time period. That
doesn't have to necessarily be the only
location, it's just one example. This
movement into a refugium would likely have
been accompanied by a population
bottleneck as you can imagine. If things
are stressful in a given environment then
usually what we see is a reduction in
population size. Conversely, you could
also think about it in a slightly
different way, maybe there was some
stressful climatic experience and that
these other populations simply went
extinct, okay? So you have local
extinction events for example here in
Eastern Africa, or Northern Africa, and
only a population persists in one
geographic region again indicated here by
these little Xs in Southern Africa. Then
what would have happened, right? So then
at a 100,000 years ago, we know humans
began expanding again. So if they did sort
of localize to one specific place on the
African continent, what would that then
look like? They would have expanded into
these other regions again, but maybe they
absorbed individuals that persisted there.
So maybe there wasn't complete extinction
events in these other geographic regions,
or indeed maybe all these individuals that
were living in Eastern and Northern Africa
did completely go extinct and we don't see
their signatures in the human genome. So
this I want to sort of end by emphasizing
that this is a single origin model for the
modern human species, but it fits the data
actually quite nicely because of this
shallow divergence we see in the genetic
lineages. And I will emphasize that there
is a lot of additional sequencing that
needs to be done particularly in African
populations were we probably have the
fewest samples of full human genomes that
have been sequenced. And we really need to
actually think explicitly about testing
these models in a context that connects
the genetic data with the
paleo-anthropological information. And I
will stop right there. Thank you very
much.
♪ [music] ♪